well good afternoon everyone and welcome
to the Tuesday May 7 2019 session in our
series on entrepreneurship and Asian
high-tech industries today we're going
to address a topic an aspect of the
ecosystem for Entrepreneurship that has
not been well known for success in Japan
we're going to look at the role of large
companies in partnering with startup
companies and what kind of an impact
that can have on the ecosystem for
start-up companies success in a country
like Japan remember we've talked about
this on several sessions in this series
already very first session with Tim
Romero we talked about how the Japanese
large companies remember Tim was acting
as the CTO for the venture capital
investments inside Tokyo Electric Power
Company so we've had a little bit to do
with this before but I'm delighted that
we have a speaker who has really
dedicated his recent career to
establishing an ecosystem for research
and development from the standpoint of a
major Japanese corporation so our
speaker today is mr. molto nishihara
who is the CTO chief technology officer
of NEC corporation he's had this role
since last month and before he was CTO
which is really not only in charge of
all of the research and development
activities inside NEC he's also
responsible for innovation strategy and
also technology investment management of
the company's intellectual properties so
he will be concerned today not only with
inbound open innovation how to obtain
new knowledge and partnership with
startup companies for the sake of the
company strapped to the NEC strategy but
also outbound technology
open innovation which is a part of the
Chesbro model for open innovation but
it's not talked about so much so I'm
really looking forward to see how this
plays out today his mr. Nakata's
previous job before he was CTO was to be
the senior vice president in charge of
the central research labs at NEC which
included not only the main lab in Japan
but also laboratories in the United
States China Singapore and Germany
before that he held general manager
positions in research including cloud
system research and also system platform
research and before that he was involved
in R&D he also has experience in product
development and he has experience and
the business divisions the business
units at NEC he got his master's in
computer engineering at electrical
Computer Engineering from Carnegie
Mellon and his bachelors from University
of Tokyo in mathematical engineering and
information physics while he was in his
senior vp role in charge of NEC labs
first of all he established new labs in
Israel and also in India and he started
to focus on this whole kind of ecosystem
concept and today we're going to hear
about how he's using this concept to
really speed up innovation inside NEC
with partnerships and with startup
companies and I should let Mitch honest
on tell the rest thanks very much for
coming today we're very happy that you
can be here ok thank you thank you
[Applause]
so okay so thank you for introduction of
me and professor - art and a great talk
about initiating new strategy for in in
Bondurant of innovation and first of all
I have a one question for you and how
many of you have never heard of in VC
until today so hard
honestly already I saw one hand so you
know ABC very well
okay yeah it's very happy surprise for
me okay and
doesn't seem to work well
yeah I'm sorry there are some nice
compression and so before starting the
content of a discussion I would like to
introduce the some of the initiative
what the initial profile and the
pre-show
see me that is a short video
[Music]
orchestrating a brighter world and II
see now you're a little bit increased
knowledge about NDC and and the energy
is the first joint venture between Japan
and the United States and we established
in 1899 I are glad to see this picture
this is the picture of the employee of
Tova's ages of machine work which is the
Thomas Edison Company and this guy his
name is the mr. Roderick he the only
Japanese person who worked under the
Thomas Edison so he and his founder of
Elysee and so the meter and energy has
very good relationship at a very
original connection to the United States
and the venture spirit and when he back
to who came back to Japan he started the
business importing the United States
product like a telecom the telephone and
the telecom equipment and the network
infrastructure equipment another history
of NEC and now energy is now focusing on
job making a social value creation and
we defined as three domain areas and we
try to make a social subdivision and
those topics are originated with the
SDGs activity populated by a United
Nations and now I'm going to see today
if society is classic major challenges
arising from the rapid increase in world
population inequalities in economic and
resource distribution and
NAC is already working to optimize
available resources to bring happiness
to people using biometrics to ensure
meals for children raising agricultural
productivity via e-voucher x' our desire
is to work together with our valued
partners and customers to co-create
solutions that address social challenges
to help realize NEC safer cities
creating a more safe and secure society
for everyone including watchlist
detection by facial recognition
[Music]
helping to build a society that offers
equal opportunities and efficient
services enabling a pleasant and
stress-free lifestyle
[Music]
NEC provides diverse solutions from the
ocean floor to outer space
and its global operations enable
co-creation on every continent
[Music]
NEC is a global leader in ICT it's
unique number one innovative
technologies in biometrics and AI
underpin solutions for society that
create new social value
[Music]
together for a brighter future
orchestrating a brighter world and II
see yes and you see is a company to make
social solution as shown in this video
and you see pay particular attention to
providing safer cities and value chain
innovation
Sanofi will endeavor to create a diverse
social body by promoting businesses in
these two sectors and so I will show us
some of the example of what we doing and
by the year 2050 and the other operation
is going to 1.6 times more than the
current population so do you know that
means this means that the increase of
the movement of the people and the
scenes and also increase of the crime
and dangers and terrorism so obviously
for the safe and secure urban cities we
need a public safety system and the
Smart Response system and the digital
governance system and now initial trials
create those kind of system by the AI
technology and ICT and IOT technologies
this is the example integrate Argentina
so can you believe 80% reduction vehicle
served after implementing our
surveillance to the job the solution was
enabled by our image recognition
technology with some other AI
technologies
another example is the labor shortage
problem there is a serious lack of
manpower in the retail industry in
advanced countries like Japan where a
steward must be operated efficiently
using a minimum manpower we provide
absolute over labor this type store
which enhanced both of the customer
experience and the operational
excellence in customer experience and
she provided walkthrough entering and
the registered as payment for customers
by bio-identical technology and then she
also provided the commendation of
product for each customer through
digital signage system in operation
excellence and she reduced the labor
load of a to operation by introducing a
I purchased clock to estimate the
customer need and the IOT facility
management system so say this person can
to Ho Kus can I can to focus more on the
customer relations and this is a a
couple with the example but we have a
lot of activity all over the world for a
hunting a social as problem and
associates all regions and this is a
background or when you see what Ramos is
doing in the business sector so now I'd
like to talk about R&D sector
introduction of energy laboratories we
have a seven research laboratories all
over the world including United States
we have a turrible teenagers United
States and Germany and Israel and India
Singapore and China and Japan one half
thousand researchers working on the
order of the world
and the search area is like this one
ai and platform since our direction is
the social part of creation which means
that basically we have to digitize the
real world and based on that
visualization we have to analyze and
make a some kind of prescription for the
social body and those sector visualise
analysis prescription is pretty
compatible function with AI so data
science is the most important technology
inside a a machine and that the process
is also accomplished by computing
network security and the high D rival
computing and broad bandwidth while
networking and the secure system is
supporting that they are processing so
there our technology research it
focusing on those areas and this is a
slide of the our illicit AI technologies
visualization analysis prescription and
the most of the technology have been
achieved by energy laboratories and we
call that the brand name initiative wise
it's a technology brand name also I
would like touch of the Pumas about
technology this is a achievement of a
conference presentation in artificial
intelligence areas we look check that we
check that the old papers in the most
highly ranked conferences and we
position the number five
in total over total area from 2000 and
if you look at three over three years we
have initiated syringe ranked eighth
eighth and I think the size of the
company and the domain of the initiative
business area so initial power was
pretty good what Anna told AAA we have a
very good achievement in the security
area networking area so that is the
condition of the academic conference
achievement and I also I'd like to
introduce and show our researchers and
some of the researchers is a very very
famous and for example Hiroshima Aikido
Japanese he the deal of a face
recognition and the energy achieved that
most consecutive neva benchmarking in n
is T and not more is a leader of a
pigeon recognition he's also the
professor of University of California
San Diego in the hospital is a inventor
of the torch it which is a very famous
OSS and others and also objects point
out that the former in which his
employees you know the young Luca he win
ACM Turing award last year and he was in
the same Louie and he he worked in the
initial level of three America and the
bloody Mubarak is an inventive support
vector machine
he also was a energy employee and mr.
Nakamura he's one of the basic compound
Computing's
inventions so I'd like to point out we
have a very good to decide to record and
the besides people here so my job is the
house monitored how to make a business
based on those people's output then I
think we have known much of the energies
Hamas initiate capability then I will
like to deep down in the initial you
status of op opie no better
as you see inbound of innovation is a
very important for large companies but
this is very typical cases large company
invest the startups and incorporate
their technology inside in DC to make
solutions
so impact of innovation is for expanding
value over initial solutions other CTO I
have a found I investor venture capital
venture businesses to make a new
collaboration of a business team you
need awareness II and what this is very
important and I'm very looking for the
field further collaboration with the
startups especially in Silicon Valley
but it is every every company is doing
this one then I'd like to talk about the
outer path of innovation and this is
what makes initiative special and so
unique
riten now I don't see any other large
company to do this type of that outward
of innovation I know there are so many
startups so many spin out in the Silicon
Valley but what what I try to say in
this presentation is slightly different
from the style over the Silicon Valley
first ball I direct share the my
understanding over the problems in large
companies so first problem is where are
the talented people obviously startup
company we may be they have a lot of
talented people they make an innovation
they make a good status they make
assumption something good business I
agree with that but also there are so
many good people and the people Eli the
cooperation especially in Japan were
other countries because Japan doesn't
have so much large
venture capital startup market the
people good people with talented people
a food to work in the logic company the
problem is these people in the startup
had much opportunity to talk to discuss
with the many body of the market people
but large companies people talented
people hidden in the light Mogadishu
they don't have so much opportunity to
talk with many diverse marketing people
the dr. Barthold
the other one is a speed Ernest
I think that in the logic company I can
you see how the very rigid very
structural forces to the commercial
technology to inter product and that
process is very very efficient and
important for mission-critical system
and also a large infraction
something like that it is good for
current and the legacy business however
in a new business area like AI or new
type new type of the business area I
takes too long to commercialize so the
when I talked with some of the
researcher in the NEC he that he the one
of the top research all over the world
in a ITF he said at two years old we
talked with I talked with him he said
after his technology is a number one
but however travel in the two years a
computer will come out which means that
unless we can make a commercialize -
commercialize the technology in the
product in a two years we do and best
research output is meaningless
so the house accelerator commercial data
process is very important especially for
a large company so they are just
constraint
and then NEC had started a new concept
over on the ecosystem here I'm sorry
okay and energy as I said energy of the
good talented researcher and the cutting
edge technology area adult security and
we have a very good business opportunity
in the current businesses and we will
continue on the close discussion in here
to maintain and to increase the current
bills however data in a new business
when new technology domain this is not
enough so we decided to expose those
technology to the outside people if you
look at outside people some people have
a very good knowledge about what
customers needs some people have a very
good knowledge about the businesses and
maybe also the academia people have a
very good talent and also we can
incorporate external fun so normally
technologies research in the rally
cooperation is working inside a company
and collaborate with only the business
person inside the energy
it can't be excuse it's okay but at news
cases we need an other knowledge and
capability to cooperate collaborate with
us and maybe some researchers make a
spin out through this process and it's
okay still any she can get a good output
from here capital gain well maybe that
we can accelerate the commercialization
process more than doing inside energy
and in case of the startups like a
Silicon Valley maybe I think the
reminder Sally I I'm in guro but you my
understanding the people have the
greatest technology and the green to
ambition the objective that company but
because the technology isn't non qua
techno
or that company so there is some
conflict the people mind and the current
companies then they will devote that
situation but in this case it's totally
different we explode core technology
business of out here because I as I
point out before before you leave that
slide not nishikado-san so go back to
the previous slide
would you this one so right that one
so basically inside the research lab the
researcher the Reacher researcher thinks
of a real-world use case or does the
idea come from outside these what yeah
well the real-world use case in the
circle does that come from
where where yeah does that coming from
the people from the outside or does it
come from the researcher I think it's
from the outside India and I mean any
setting Equator yeah got you skated
right and this guy have the DM use case
inside NDC right the earliest case is
only limited in the channel to the
initiative business object but of course
it's much more powerful if you can get
the business knowledge
yeah the market needs from the partners
outside yeah that's right
okay that there and also address point
out the previous three and the point is
that how it's how to utilize that third
manpower resources in large company and
how to manage that as much now this one
mm-hmm
and also that how to accelerate a speed
and both problems can be solved not in
inside Raja company but sued at the
outset so which means at the core
technology and the core value and a core
direction is not only finished this one
but also can be right through this one
and as that is rated different of the
spin out cases or normcore technology
from logic company to the outside I'm
saying and also the example of this one
it's a total data it's a new company and
this person seems to be younger but I he
was a nice person
and he's a very top one of the top
researcher he the named Genevieve is
Mark II and he the youngest executive in
UC and but we decided to he did at the
new company outside NBC and we support
this one because we think that that he
know that by doing this we can absolute
that process over the quad
commercialization over technology core
technology and the actually now he left
energy and he the CEO of the new company
but pointed and we see has a very good
relationship with his company because
it's not that kind of does
I mean separate official is more like a
strategic collaboration friendship
scheme over the large company of the new
startup company
and the other other said in the ABC
provider interval property software
people captured to the total data new
company and they will feedback capital
gain receiving right of the product and
that this company also incorporate the
capita were people from outside the
other point of maximal my monetization
speed of cutting-edge core technology
outside the NUC as an independent
company that is a new type of spin out
new tab with a car blood scheme and also
I think this is very good opportunity
for their startup people because we can
incorporate any kind of official
solution cannot be done one technology
we need a budget or integration of the
technology so they salute that process
of the outer one also we we have to
incorporate many other technology
outside and and the whole process is
primary done only inside large company
but in this case even though the process
is done outside the logical body which
means there are so much opportunity for
evil for other startups company other
which page after couple other patterns
company so how to operate those kind of
the movement it's the initial stab
lished named new company initiate so
energy X is the primary goal it
incorporated this is out one technology
here and also incorporate the outside
startups innovation and make a new
solution and any six have to be launched
within a Silicon Valley
to enable repeatability block deployment
based on cutting the 80 develop the
technology seeds so is NEC only in
Silicon Valley or do you also have any
CX in in this year yeah this by NEC and
he seems the new company and the is
located in the main no park okay that
what they established their I think the
six months ago that's yeah that's last
year July yeah so I'm glad to introduce
the CEO open this year his name is CJ
wake up but is it something NASA think
of this me and Dad this is shahara the
CEO okay six and yeah as nice as I
mentioned any six was established last
year and that as he mentioned that our
mission is to generate new business
based on NEC loves the advanced
technology in the US market chase other
to create a second dot beta type of
annuities business you know and I di I
think that NEC clubs have very good
technology but I know that just having
technology does not make sense in terms
of business creation but the let's
imagine combination of the some talented
people and some business intelligence or
market insight I like to see what's
going to happen I think that maybe the
new market opportunity or business
possibilities they I like to see that so
the NEC X is now just started but the
you are any feedback or comments here
afterward I like to you
thank you yeah and now now we have a few
project following a total data and that
and the heat which in charge of this one
and and as I said also initiates provide
opportunity for potential users and the
solution partner to try out our cutting
witty and brand-new technology and as I
whatever whatever XA is we can export
our commercialized project a technology
like NEC the web not only this one we
also export are the technology inside
the initiative uh tree it is not open to
the outside but it's a it kind of the
alpha level technology but we expose
this one to oxidize the collaboration
with partners and also I'd like to point
out the other one it's a vector in the
data acceleration center and we see have
the super computing hardware and we made
it in the vector processor inside that
small box it's a kind of the networking
curve and that curve is a pretty good
for AI e processing in some food in some
type of application sometimes 100 times
faster with a five-spot compatible API
and we provide these kind of the
hardware data center system to partners
or maybe does anybody would be
interested in this technical technology
properly data center there's a science
people
then that corrode my presentation it
creates a future technology and that's
my not finished I finish my routine okay
[Applause]
so in each other son if you don't mind I
want to ask the first question huh
so one of the real typical problems with
a start-up company trying to do anything
in Japan is establishing trust you know
because you don't have a long reputation
in the company you know a startup
company wasn't started in 1899 how can
this sort of outbound if you've got
these advanced technologies that a
startup company or a business person
here might use how does those how do
those discussions actually happen this
might be something for any how to sound
- but but how how do how do you do this
hmm I mean I mean a discussion right
how do you how do you really get the
discussion starting and the outside
people how do you maybe maybe let's go
back to dot data okay
did the researcher from NEC want to
leave NEC no actually no no and he the
key person and rather he the more like
dida or the energy product and so he has
a very good passion for NEC but we think
about that the goal yeah how to activate
that he see that the person like a say
that if you make a commercial in the two
years comfortable come out that research
is meaningless
that is a comment of himself and we we
discussed how to do that so maybe we
need to use outside okay engineering
power well outside style of the
innovation outside
I don't know information ah who is the
customer something like that so that we
conclude that the best way to make it
he probably make a defense organisation
so can you say what kind of things came
in from the outside and into dot data
not from NEC what what came in from the
outside venture capital I though
currently I'm not okay okay sure no and
you're not yeah right yeah so maybe it
is it going on so yeah okay I think
especially they use that a good
engineering person she company areas and
also they have a very good to discussion
with other customers
maybe the capitalist people can Silicon
Valley so they get a very good and
actually you know that making the
commercial day sorry we need a multiple
keyboards yeah which means a very good
of hidden from every our customer what
kind of information is the most
important and he gets those kind of
information in the second body is it
easier for him to do that with the name
dot data then it would be with the name
NEC yeah I I'm not sure I think NEC is
actually a very good Randall branded
reputation right for our customers and
because unless you have that I mean
large company yeah and established
capital and the process managed
engineering research and I think that
kind of the energy reputation effect
interactivity so ideally how often would
you like to see this happen how often
yeah would you like to see one or two a
year or more or less more more MORE
okay we need it more okay I think I
think that we thought that so one of the
issues is the fear of being inside the
big company and talking to people on the
outside would they talk to any CX first
or how would this how would this proceed
for D you know what would with somebody
a researcher inside you can DC Labs yeah
would they talk to any CX first or well
how I think how do you do the next
version of dot data yeah I think yeah
you in basically that my understanding
that there is motivation in researchers
to make it business yeah that's for sure
so they've for from them the who gonna
help that that process okay the as an
insurer as I mentioned that the original
structure is the not throw that
technology to the business unity but the
come Avenue gonna be the business side
so the usually they they get some advice
from the business side whether this
technology can be more outside the code
insurer or not but usually they do not
like yeah inside okay we believe that
technology has certain potential in
terms
outside NEC existing business so in
Dustin's I think that as a CTO any
serozha gonna pick up or somebody so
this person is now we've been here in
California yeah that's okay yeah this
company is located in
I think I don't know where please but
again somebody somebody right now okay
and so any see was able to help make
this happen here in San Mateo that's
kind of unusual I think so yeah okay
yeah and also a DC is trying to sell
their product to NEC Japan customers
okay yeah yeah we have you know we have
really the customer base in Japan so the
expectation is that having some good
technology what the products for the new
company right yeah Japan he end up in
market okay and I think also they and
she have the best knowledge about the
technology its technology mm-hmm so I
still separate we have a separated but
still we're in energy that good position
so you today those technology for our
area see no and actually setting up a
POC arrangement with the Japanese
customer would take a long time in Japan
right I'm sure you that could be done
faster here okay probably does that take
based on the NEC from this structure is
little bit though other internal means
mother mm-hmm yeah we're gonna open up
some stick to doubts outside
stakeholders but in total value kill
created both NEC under new company so
increase each other sound would your
vision be to create an NEC X in other
places besides Silicon Valley to it's
possible but I think the Silicon Valley
is a most appropriate place right now
unless we can succeed here is that will
succeed here success here is a fast
probability okay yeah alright let's open
the floor to questions
go ahead yes an emetic
penny sees a famous company and of
course very well-respected this is
however a new venture and if you would
agree in a simpler world we have
innovative commercialization companies
that are either tech push where there's
technology that's trying to find a
market or unmet needs where there is a
market trying to find a solution in
Silicon Valley here in general we're
more interested if you will and unmet
needs where there is a chance for some
disruptive innovation if you have an
unmet need and are doing disruptive
innovation the cutting edge technology
is not of interest unless you know that
it in some way will enhance your ability
to meet that unmet need
how will NEC let these startup companies
in Silicon Valley and elsewhere who have
an unmet need
you know what technologies they have so
that they can look at the catalog and
decide whether or not it would make any
difference in there may be a take seeds
or a new innovation
what are you kind of a market kind of a
video well I think John's point is a lot
of innovation in Japan it looks like
it's seed driven whereas here we tend to
be more neat driven yeah and if you've
got people on the distance I'd run for
need how can they find out what
opportunities they are to benefit from
this outbound open innovation okay I
don't deny that both Saudi and actually
energy is doing it was of the ability of
any market really
innovation and the Thunder that is a
different story and that is not I mean
defect in disappear and I guess the
solution what market deliver technology
is more much more related with the type
of failure and we did it a different
type of skin not this one and in terms
of back to the question about we will
abuse and maybe in case of the term how
to make needs market need based on that
I mean that that I think the only way
only way is that we expose that every
technology every party dotted or every
capability of the people to the good
customer people who are being people to
outside and we hope they can have some
give us some time King it was a vision
to do that do you think that this will
lead to more direct communications
between NEC researchers and people
outside yeah I think those kind of
things it
yeah and may not to be of decided to
sell but the may be kind of a good
translator who know that the technology
also that sound business aspect whatever
and their industry X should be the kinds
of the company who can do that ok one
done I saw your hand next why don't you
ask me
the lab came out of NEC and become at
least up I definitely understand the
relationship with a good relationship
and friendship and this thing is
benefiting from that new startup but is
your a fear adapter and mr. Matt is
losing it's tough like brains so this is
my first question
and my second question is drop data is
based on that and still has a technology
and anything wants to like make use of
technology so it's based as the new
company is actually based on technology
so if there another case for example
that any thief who sees an opportunity
in this business but it doesn't have the
technology yet so it starts and stuff is
establishing start to start out and
recruit the top researchers to work
towards the business
okay so the first question is as you
said it there's some fear that we will
do that good researchers but I think it
matter standing in anywhere a good
researcher six opportunity to make the
research impact to thus I mean society
or the company unless they have a that
kinda opportunity inside energy they
will live a music so in that sense
anyway we need to define that a good
opportunity for him and good environment
for him that is that I think only way to
keep him expanded the energy circle and
feedback his talented capability to the
energy business so that meant the Sun
yeah yeah and now the second question
the second question is you say that
maybe we can define the missing point
and that pushes a good recital here and
Simek happen yeah I think I worried who
is that and and that I think that
discussion is a may be related in I
don't know discussion with him which
means that we need some the finest
market segment and there was a solution
segment and I put some current
technology and startup technology and
see the some missing core and that is
all we have done in another scheme and I
think definitely whether even to do that
we need a good technical nation inside
here not a limited the information
through their current channel okay
yeah this is an interesting kind of
application between you know what NEC
has it's really strong but the whole
world is a very big world and you
already have research labs and now what
seven different
in addition to Japan yeah and there was
a city or
I'd like to point out that this is the
Aminu challenging but also this kind of
that process is also very important for
industry and actually this process is
now maintained that the energy straight
right now and I'm also in charge of this
one but making the new growth area new
outside area we need to think about a
different type type of the scheme
ok so I've seen several hands people
have been raising their hands I gotta
say Prakash I saw your hand first you're
down front
go ahead want to ask do you see a dot
date and I company set up by a total
stranger to talk to him so a dot a
little company so the trust factors
taken care off he's very bright and he's
not an employee of yours so to you to
any see he's a stranger
what is that bright idea and I
understand the certain segment market
and the question is there may be a way
of marrying some things that are inside
an IABP
with what he is doing to produce a
viable product do you every start that
what do you see this as largely being a
way for you to use your own employees
and throw them off the cuttings of roses
into the garden so first of all from the
company top point point of view and if
the new company invented by the outside
people and still they are intention to
make a good relationship relationship it
doesn't matter
we just incorporated with them because
that goal is not I mean personal
scheme or something exactly its goal to
make a good solution with the goal to
somehow and accelerate that the time the
commercialization yeah the
commercialization thought that that yes
good sense yeah and it's okay
and as long as these people have the
gute a champion here but maybe this new
company invented by outside people may
have a lot of limey
good friend outside then you see and
maybe and noticing people who deserve to
be encouraged you can well and I will
give my opinion I see a possibility for
Industrial Development arbitrage here
because a lot of data analytics have
moved forward here faster than they've
moved in the Japan market and so this
would be a significant speed up
possibility to send somebody from NEC
over here to develop the market here and
then gradually build up what has to be
built up with the old traditional
customers in Japan that this could this
could definitely happen first that's all
your hand yeah I see a tension between
your you talked about a little bit the
inbound Greeks the process that art
exists that you've got I've assumed lots
of business units that are somehow
funding the R&D want to be customers of
the R&D yet they see potential
competition's competitors could you talk
just a little bit about first of all the
allocation process of how you determine
internal development what you're what
you're putting your research in based on
internal customers and then the next
step will be how do you see tension
managing the tension between when I
start this kind of activity and she so
we have a lot of discussion with the
business unit and definitely when I push
out the some some groups outside and you
see that kind of the delivered by those
team cannot compete with the current
business
and we have very careful over that kind
of thing and so they're they're a lot of
management discussed and I so that's
that my answer so many discussed and
you're saying that there's internal
discussions and some prioritization of
your projects and how they're funded
driven by business unit direction this
is all incremental business outside of
what those business units would do is
that sort of the general focus of any CX
is non competitive spinouts or
pre-competitive well non competitive
with the current business unit
activities I mean for sure I would guess
it has to be but it's interesting
because this is clearly a vehicle
discussion I can't can I I should say
that for seven years now NEC has been
one of our major research supporters and
one of the things that we're doing our
surveys of startup companies worldwide
in particular areas of new technology
and so I know that NEC labs in some ways
has a very good knowledge of the most
recent trends on the business side of
startups I would expect and this is
Richard talking right I would expect
that the business units are very
customer focused and customer driven by
what the existing customers many of whom
are in Japan where a lot of these
analytics have not developed as much a
lot of the new businesses here have not
really reached Japan yet so in some ways
labs is more up-to-date in their
knowledge of new business than is our
the business units I can say that don't
you say that
we have to choose the business domain
carefully and I mean new activity cannot
compete with a current businesses so
that but in that case it in the.net
cases with total new areas and which
doesn't exist in the current Japan and
actually but making the total data that
the revocable could be very good
generate a good bit vineyard in even
japan for the new customers so the how
to define the domain or something it's
important for a large company go ahead
my question we Elsa this is you're
making government especially and every
ships headquarters or may be similar to
special products outside any CX and the
current tool of novelty and but I think
to make a new businesses or maybe I find
a new opportunities I think they mean
that the any six should be in charge of
the otherwise that may be outside the
people doesn't know the situation in the
second body so as you can see acts
should deal that country they need to
excel to the left
here fill the idea of setting up on a
dark data like
does the lab say we have this
interesting technology what can you do
mr. NEC at home or does a DC excitation
for all of these opportunities
tell us how which one of you we would
like to would like to work with us to
explain yeah I think that there are the
the the what development you can do is
expose our own technology to uh to to
the MCX
and the initiate has some kind of time
in the working process without such
people for the and also the energy
technology and and that generate some
kind of that opportunity of the new new
business or the new solutions okay
we cannot yes maybe some time from the
statical point of view and she had to
quote wanton do something in a some
areas and maybe I may ask him to make a
some special project that kind of thing
but I think it's more like I mean not
any ordinary to focus yeah let me make I
see several hands go right yeah yeah
going back to the question they my
mission is to create option scenario I
mean that option a is the business
waiting anything
let let be you take it or option B which
will be created by any CX the other
option for anything so which is the best
so in case of the doc data does speed
wise and the kind of the competitiveness
the the executive decided let's call the
the outside business model the kind of
things I like to the proposed to the
IADC executive so that's number one
and then also the technology it's the be
you sign or IEC
not know where about the the outside
their territory I mean they don't know
anything for the outside world but then
they they cannot make this young without
keep it or let it go so the the actual
project is starting from the no decision
at all then but we get some approval to
make to let us create some option
scenario first then we come back to NEC
and which is the best scenario and I
like to fight with the such a
competition inside NEC but that is the
whole idea and the I like the what I'm
saying is probably I wanna provide as
some decision the information what
decision the material to the executive
which is the best okay thank you
I see several hands I did see your hand
first I think and then then you okay
different I
I do not know me about that computer
activity and the but I don't see any
I mean Japanese logic company make new
startups in the Silicon Valley and yeah
maybe some but I don't see so many and
so I don't have any feeling about yeah I
mean I mean we don't we don't have an
intention to compete with a kind of
scheme overall on the system with other
companies we just think that this way
could be a reasonable for making a
monetization and now we are trying
challenge so this one yeah doctor data
transition yeah okay second question
related to the yeah
recently working with a lot of Japanese
logic operation injury they always set
up Allah said I'd obviously sabbatical
they probably your customer banking here
and they are looking for all kind of new
technologies
I was wondering any CRM is they're very
very good at best technologies from
argumentation and don't you think it's
much more efficient and speedy to try
this type out of innovation we do a
Japanese domestic research
commercialization scheme in Japan and we
have actually we did a lot of
accomplishment here we are I didn't show
those kind of thing here but a dotted am
an ordinary method and but in order to
obtain the new market and a new type of
the businesses I think as improbably
kampala the best places and so we didn't
do so much in here until now and that is
the first time and also I direct sale
and maybe you may miss Tandon done
something and the energy is a rubber one
thousand researchers and a five hundred
researcher is working in Japan now five
other researchers working outside of
Japan and du-deta cases and inventor is
a Japanese person but as I went up today
I mean I don't know maybe yeah okay this
this slide you see that many other
researchers working outside and okay you
see the employee of the past employee
like this one this one this one it's
very famous people and very famous
people and he was a poster ex-employee
here with Japan so I much very showing
how
make their capability monetize to energy
product
so maybe you should understand and then
it's not a Japanese case it's more like
a large corporations case it how to use
a good resources in about the
cooperation to make something happen and
yeah good carry good your question I'm
going fishing
station student that I can say okay the
two questions one is I was very
interested when you talked about the
middle school yet CBO this is dry
conservation and one citation of great
researchers
sometimes the Michigan CEO is the Lord
and also great pity
how do you feel
person I mean it is easy once you
exploit this is my business
it's remains with the latest
technologies or is it once you destruct
system easy as a first question second
question is I like and he said um fund
organization is our internal ecosystem
ecosystem is something how you perceive
the state where players in the ecosystem
are barely any bullied
though how do you make sure that they
see as a presence centralized
governments in a persistent in other
words with 900 plus Japanese companies
already involved also hire a i4z
companies already in play incidentally
let me make sure that some stocks are
incentivized so how about that question
and I think that I mean I know I became
CTO last month and now 35 days so I mean
still in the writing process and the
difficulty I think that a CTO admission
into included and not only disruptive
technology of switcher but also that
very important for the current
businesses and I'm pretty much this
appeal responsibility for the how to
maintain how to grow up the current
business also and in order to do that I
will do that something other pop task
decide this one and maybe pop innovation
or envelope admission is a critically
important factor for enhancing the
current leadership and also I as I said
involved it also important and and I am
working in the also desert type of
machine and I'm the trade protection
focus on that how to make monetization
of the our technology current technology
to give a much much opportunity to the
market side okay so uh demo argument
and the second question about
incentivizing startups to want to work
with NEC it's a competitive environment
yeah yeah
second question so the second question
is I think it's a very important but
difficult question and we start this
activity last year and I think we need a
much more lessons from here and so maybe
we recruit good people who know the
style and the ecosystem or a management
and also maybe we have to change that
mindset of the energies researchers 20
years okay good
Walter sack National Lab I have one
question what kind of financial
arrangement with the outsider in order
to motivate a partnership with Angie's
to the outside the people okay yeah I
have a as the CTO I have a pump but they
say to me oh you know if I can you know
again put in my opinion on this NEC has
some of the world leading technology if
you're in a particular space and you see
may have the technology you want to work
with so I think that would be part of
yeah and yeah anything else I mean any
said the global company other training
and so many channels to the main company
so which mean that if we can use your
technology inside out solution that
could be scalable to the many places
many countries and the main system and
that can be a go-to incentive for
startups so we're getting close to the
end of the session if you don't mind I'd
like to end up with a slightly different
question a lot of what you're focusing
on is artificial intelligence IOT
systems that are really hot topics in
the news how do you see the corporate
sector moving forward to solve some of
the problems with data protection and
privacy protection what do you think
would be a good way for industry to move
forward in this
oh yeah it's a very hot topic yeah and
okay maybe I'm su soda sounds right and
yeah yeah we think that that kind of
discussion is very very important and
actually NEC has announced that
yeah provide socially acceptable AI hmm
and we need a safety security
interference obsessive to anyway privacy
issues and beneficial issues and a human
right is a very very important factor so
we define this kind of the principle in
April and we are willing to collaborate
with any kind of the social sectors so I
mean it is very simple technology should
be for the benefit of the people benefit
of the society we have been very careful
for dealing with that and that might an
initiative population yeah ok we got
yeah I think that's a really good note
for us to in the formal session on we
have refreshments outside please stay
and meet our speakers we've got several
people visiting from NEC look forward to
talking to everybody outside thank you
so much
[Applause]